[Applause]
they call her the lady political
activist turned politician and sangsuchi
[Applause]
[Music]
force from power in myanmar by a
military coup
today she was found guilty of incitement
and breaking covert 19 restrictions
she was sentenced to four years
imprisonment cut to two after a partial
pardon
she's facing a show trial it has nothing
to do with
justice or rule of law everything to do
with destruction of democracy
destruction of freedom distractions of
the dreams and the hope of the people of
myanmar for democracy and freedom
[Applause]
the 76 year old is no stranger to prison
in 2010 she was released from house
arrest after spending around 15 years in
detention since 1989.
many hoped this would be the start of
true democracy in myanmar
but the military wasn't ready to let go
of power since february's coup more than
a thousand people have been killed by
junta forces
su chi is one of more than ten thousand
who've been arrested
myanmar's ousted president was also
given a four-year sentence supporters
say the charges are bogus and aimed at
keeping both leaders from power but this
is just the start ansan tsuchi faces a
host of extra charges and if she's found
guilty could be sentenced to more than a
hundred years
from fledgling democracy to failed state
life in myanmar is now characterized by
violence and fear
the uk foreign secretaries called
today's verdicts another appalling
attempt to stifle opposition and
suppress freedom
but calls for ansang suchi's release
will likely go unheeded
politically they may be in control in
the capital but on the ground um they're
facing stiff resistance and i think that
their actions against angstromsuchi and
the president today portray that
nervousness and that they're not
actually in control on the ground
widely popular at home and sang tsuchi's
international reputation was battered by
her failure to condemn the military's
attacks on the rohingya in 2017
that same military now holds her future
in its hands
it will decide when she will be released
if she will ever see freedom again
siobhan robbins sky news bangkok